and our next speaker is from them and I
believe she talked about the rich
deliverance course up in regeneration
for today yeah biological data thank you
very much yeah so um hi everyone thank
you for having me I think the ordinate
organizers for inviting me
um so I'm Shannon mccurdy and I just
joined ancestry.com as a statistical
geneticist but until recently I was a
computational biology postdoc here at UC
Berkeley and I was co-advised by
co-mentor for my postdoc by Leo packer
and Lisa Barcelos and just so you have
my full history full disclosure my PhD
was in physics so I've had wide wide and
varied interests and the work that I'm
going to talk to you talk with you about
today is work from the end of my postdoc
and it's on Ridge regression and
deterministic Ridge leverage core
sampling and this work is on archive and
to appear at nips and so just some high
just a high level overview people here
even in this room have considered
randomized sampling with rich leverage
scores and people in the community have
investigated deterministic sampling
though not with rich leverage of course
and so I sort of brought those two
pieces together to think about
deterministic sampling with rich
leverage scores and then hopefully
brought it to an even new direction for
some things for it in a new direction by
pairing this rich leverage sampling with
Richard Gresham so that's just a
high-level so I'd like to give you some
motivation at the back of my mind I
always have this problem that I have
moderately big data so what do I mean by
moderately big data it's too big to
really inspect by hand but you aren't
limited by the memory of your machine or
the computational time for your
algorithm so here we're thinking also
that our data is on the Heidemann
régime so we have many more features
than we do samples and this area occurs
very frequently in biology where we have
a data matrix a where we have at the
rows of the data matrix are samples and
these are from individuals or from
tumors or from cells and the columns are
different features that come from
in my case genomic data so this could be
a single nucleotide polymorphisms called
snips which look at different loci and
in your genome
it could be gene expression signatures
could be mutations methylation our
ability to collect very genomic data is
very large for a single sample but we
don't always have nearly as many samples
as we do the ability to collect
biological data from that sample so this
case occurs and so we've measured all of
these features but this question that I
have is maybe not all of them are
important so we could reduce the
dimensionality of our problem by doing
something like SVD or pca on our on our
data matrix a but the linear combination
of columns that we would get when we
reduce our data matrix to the smaller
feature set is not very interpretable
for a biologist who's interested in
finding a set of genes to interrogate
for example as being important for their
system so interpretability is really
important and we'd like to perhaps
instead of getting linear linear
combinations of features we would like
to know exactly like a subset of
features and so to do this we need some
way of ranking and selecting columns and
so this high-level question in the back
of my mind is can we select columns of
this data matrix a which and create from
that a column sub matrix which I will be
calling C that preserves nice properties
of a and I'm going to unpack each of
those bits of the statement throughout
the throughout the talk and so then once
we figured out which columns and
are important we might also want to do
something with those columns and that's
something that I'm gonna consider doing
is Ridge regression with the smaller
feature set so to get there I'm gonna
talk a little bit about leverage and the
different some different flavors of
leverage then just very briefly
deterministic versus random I'm going to
talk about some bounds that come out of
this procedure and some experimental
data from tumor samples at the very end
so classical average scores or the
leverage of course that were first
introduced in the literature they
measure the importance of each column
which in my case is a feature in the
column space of a and so this is a
really nice intuitive definition which
some people in the audience the Cameron
and Chris are part of introducing this
definition of leverage scores you can
see that that the leverage score sort of
captures how easy it is to write a
single column of your matrix in terms of
a linear call a linear combination of
the other columns in your matrix so if
this problem is easy if it's easy to
write one column as a linear combination
then tau is small if this problem is
hard then tau is large and tau ranges
from zero to one and the Tau is your
leverage score yes no you bought the X
that obtains it
I believe it is all the columns are they
worth the same if all the columns of air
the same then then X is equally weighted
and all of in all of its components and
so the leverage score is something like
1 over the number of columns X is X is
useful right guess you yeah yeah it's a
is full rank and so you have to get you
have to if you want if you if you were
in the case that oh yeah yeah well if
just you can say you can write this a
little bit more carefully if a is not
full rank and then you have to yeah okay
sorry
so an alternate and equivalent
definition which is maybe more familiar
to people is little the leverage score
where you think of the leverage score as
the norm of each column of a with
respect to this inner product where
you're the matrix that you're using to
take care inner product with respect to
okay so so that so so you're you're sort
of measuring the length of your columns
with respect to this norm given by the a
a transpose of your complete matrix and
it's inverse or pseudo inverse if a is
not full rank and so if you recall your
singular value decomposition you can
rewrite your leverage score yet again as
the sum for each row you for each row
and your lunch singular vector you sum
over the over the columns of the
truncated left singular sorry
right singular vector V and so sorry you
sum over the columns make sure I said
that right you sum over the columns of
the matrix of the right singular vectors
so okay this is a leverage score what
has it been used for well it as I said
it quantifies the importance of each
column I and the range space of a and so
they've been used in regression
Diagnostics outlier detection and
randomized matrix algorithms and
historically leverage scores were used
to select informative samples but as the
case where we're collecting many more
features than samples has occurred
they've also been used to start picking
informative features and informative
features setting is the one that I am I
am I'm interested in so if you look at
this expression you see that the that
the write singular vectors are kind of
important for the leverage scores and
you might this begs the question are all
of the singular vectors important
important in your mind are they're all
equally important and so perhaps if your
spectrum looks something like this you
may not care about all the singular
vectors you may not care about the ones
with small singular values and so you're
left with a question well how do I want
to treat these small cing these singular
vectors or small singular values do I
want to omit them or do I want to dilute
them and both approaches have been taken
in literature so the first approach is
to just omit them and if you do that
your lead
a subspace leverage scores and so there
you just project onto your matrix into
the top K singular components and you
use that to take your norm
well semi norm because there are these
it's possible to get zero directions and
so what this does in your leverage score
is it says alright I'm going to continue
to sum over my over my right singular
vectors but I'm only going to sum over K
of them rather than all n of them and so
you can create this really nice
geometric picture where you've sphere
sized to the columns of your data and so
each column is a point on this and and
leverage score is essentially the radius
of the column on this on this picture so
large leverage score large leverage
score columns are ones with large radius
but this approach has been noted in the
literature that this taking the top top
the top the projection onto the top K
singular vectors of a matrix is not
always unique and it can be sensitive to
matrice perturbation perturbations and
so it's sort of not a very stable
operation to do and moreover your norm
here has is not full rank so maybe
there's something that's a little bit
more natural and so that leads to the
second approach which is instead of
emitting these directions entirely we
are going to just dilute them and so we
have our a transpose and and our int and
our pseudo inverse and we're going to
regularize it by adding a piece that's
proportional to the identity so that
this matrix now becomes full rank and
for the purposes of this talk I'm always
going to take this love this
regularization parameter which is
proportional to the Frobenius norm of
the complement of the of the top K
singular vectors that we care most about
because that gives the available balance
but so we can sort of complete our
matrix by at
this portion proportional to the
identity and we're going to say this is
how we're going to measure distance and
so if you use your SVD you can work out
what these components are and you can
see that now and if we now what we've
done is that we have these singular
values but in the denominator we've
added this piece which is proportional
to the regularization parameter which
means that the small eigen the small
singular values matter less
proportionally than the large singular
values and you can draw a similar
picture except for now contours of
constant leverage are ellipses rather
than circles so these these leverage
scores are very nice because they are
they they sort of address some of the
problems that came up in the rank K
leverage scores they're much more
they're much more stable and they behave
a lot more a lot more predictably if you
do matrix perturbations and they change
monotonically if you add or subtract
columns to your matrix a and this is um
work by the Musco brothers here and and
Michael Cohen who made this important
realization and then also Michael
Mahoney and his collaborator recognized
that Ridge leverage scores were very
natural in context of kernel regression
so Ridge leverage scores hopefully I've
convinced you these are very this is a
very sensible quantity to look at and so
this is the quantity that I'm interested
in for you in in how I'm going to rank
when I how I'm going to rank and select
my columns and my and my algorithm for
choosing a column subset so
deterministic versus random I'm here at
a randomized numerical linear algebra
conference telling you about a
deterministic algorithm so why am i
doing that well the main reason is
interpretability
and so biologists when they not just
biologists but people in general do
happen to like if you run a procedure or
an algorithm you will get the same
answer every time so you have some
confidence and your results and what
they mean there's no failure probability
and then under certain conditions which
I'll touch on briefly through my talk
like the bounds are that are actually
available if your data has a certain if
your data has a certain signature so
this is why I'm interested in a
deterministic algorithm also just I'd
like to make the argument the pitch for
pure curiosity there were these nice
bounds for randomized algorithms for
rich leverage scores and the question
that I was curious about was like well
can you do this in the deterministic
setting - it seems like you really
should but nobody had done it so and
even in the deterministic sense if you
could do everything in exactly with what
it the solution is not unique because
you could change say just the columns of
the Oh matrix and run the AI problem
again one gets different you know
different selection of columns they may
have the same properties in terms of
singular values but they are different
yeah so I think the argument is a lot of
work in Berkeley I prefer deterministic
hang on oh okay great well um I would
love more pointers to the literature you
can let me know later so yeah so so do
let me know
so the deterministic sampling algorithm
and this talk is based on work by
Papadopoulos I apologize if I
mispronounced his name and his
co-authors and so basically what we're
going to do is we're going to calculate
the ridge leverage score for each column
and we're going to line up all of our
columns according to their ranked Ridge
leverage score so that they decrease and
then we're going to be greedy and we're
going to take all of the columns that
have large rich leverage score and we're
going to drop all of the columns a small
rich leveraged score and the real power
in this algorithm is that you can add up
the leverage scores of all of the
columns that you've dropped which is
sort of this
under the curve and that's proportional
to the error that you're going to get in
your later bounce and norm so this is
this algorithm was introduced for rank K
subspace leverage scores and it just
takes a couple adaptations to make it
work in the setting of Ridge leverage
course but the Ridge leverage scores
give you a much richer set of bounds
essentially because you have regularize
your your your matrix with what you're
taking your inner product so that brings
to me to the balance like what can we do
with this and so these are these nice
properties that we're thinking of when
we're trying to select the columns of a
like what are we preserving about our
matrix a when we do this so the first
property and the one that I'm going to
talk about in more detail in the next
slide is a spectral bound and this is an
extremely powerful tool so I'll talk
about it next another property that we
might be interested in his column subset
selection and this in my context is used
as a feature selection algorithm and the
idea here is that you want to find a
small number of columns that approximate
the column space of a nearly as well as
the topcase singular vectors of a so so
this is a this is a question that has
been interrogated before with leverage
score sampling then there's also ranked
a projection cost preservation so bounds
of this type are important because they
mean that low ranked projection problems
can be solved with your column subsets
meant matrix rather than your full
matrix and you're still preserving the
cost the projection cost and this has
implications for k-means clustering
because the k-means objective function
can be written in terms of a projection
matrix and this has been interrogated
before again for randomized Ridge
leverage sampling and the question was
can you get a similar bound for a ridge
leverage course I'm sorry for
deterministic sampling with Ridge
leverage scores and then lastly there's
a question of what are the number of
selected can this ever be better that
can the bounds on deterministic sampling
ever be better than available bounds on
randomized and this was a question that
was interrogated in terms of rank kate
leverage score deterministic sampling
but was unknown for rich liver score
sampling and so of course the answer to
all of these bounds is like yes they
exist this is possible for deterministic
sampling with rich leverage scores I'm
not going to write them all out formally
instead what I'm going to tell you is a
little bit more about is the spectral
bound which is the most powerful among
them and allows you to get a lot of the
other results so the spectral bound that
we have is that a column sub matrix of C
from a selected with the deterministic
rich leverage score sampling algorithm
that I sketched for you briefly before
will obey the following property that
column sub matrix C is less than so C C
transpose is less than a transpose on
the right and greater than this quantity
on the left and so this is an additive
multiplicative spectral bound and I
should probably explain for you what is
this symbol here so this symbol here
this less than or greater than sign is
called the loner ordering and it's a
generalization of the real line to
hermitian matrices so what this means is
just like for real numbers we know that
two is already greater than one point
five always greater than one point five
you can say that a matrix is greater
than another matrix if it is hermitian
and dot products with respect to that
matrix if a dot product for all vectors
X with respect to one matrix are less
than dot products with that same vector
X with another matrix then they the
matrix for which all dot product
products are greater is greater than the
other matrix and the loner ordering so
that's a lot of words so I hope write
that down if you have
is that not visible
I think they saw this is portable with a
sanitation is everybody here good with
that okay so can I ask a quick question
is London to the value that christen
camera have their paper so just not so
this I didn't think about trying to vary
lambda to that value of lambda two is
definitely very important for the yeah
yeah okay so the loner or during the
reason why it's so powerful it gives you
ordering on eigen values ordering on
traces or hang on distances so this is
this is a very nice thing and I should
also mention that this is the bound does
that holds if you chosen C with a
randomized algorithm and you've you Bree
waited your columns proportional to the
leverage score which is proportional to
the sampling probability so you can see
that the bound on the bottom is the same
but the bound on the top is a little bit
worse than that's because of the
randomized sample are you interested in
a or a transpose I think so it sort of
depends on what you're interested in
doing Oh me I am interested in the
singular values and I'm interested in
doing Ridge regression with a and it
turns out the bounds of this type which
hopefully I can get to by the end of the
talk actually depend this is a very
powerful statement that allows me to
talk about Ridge regression with a so
you'll have to hold on just for a little
bit to see where that goes
so just to give you some intuition the
top part you basically get for free from
your selection matrix so I won't talk
about that the bottom part is a little
bit harder to get but not very hard
basically what you do is you look at the
difference between a transpose and you
decide the
I'm gonna multiply it on both sides by
the identity matrix but I'm gonna write
the identity matrix in a special way I'm
gonna break down the identity matrix and
to you into NT you are Sigma where this
is your singular this is your singular
value matrix which has this extra bit
added to it and this is invertible and
you transpose and uu transpose because i
have all n components so this is square
so this is equal to 1 so this is what
I'm going to call my identity matrix I'm
going to multiply from both sides and
then this piece so this is u Sigma bar
Sigma bar inverse u transpose and then I
have this piece in the middle and then
I'm going to call this quantity Y and if
you were doing randomized sampling you
would use a matrix Berenstein bound to
bound Y but it turns out that when
you're doing this deterministic sampling
you can bound this quantity by taking
the trace and that's proportional to or
that is the error for the leverage
scores that you have left out so this is
nice because you can just actually do
that do this thank you so I talked about
nice properties of a like column subset
for production cost preservation I give
you like ok so actually
the expression is a little bit messy so
maybe what I will just tell you rather
than to take the time to write that out
is that if you have if you have in a
particular setting where your leverage
scores decay with a power law of power
law profile then you can bound how many
columns you choose with this algorithm
and if coefficient in that power-law
decay is greater than two then the
number of columns just deterministically
sampled is order K and so you can write
an exact expression which is a little
complicated which I can write at the end
which basically shows you when you will
choose fewer columns with deterministic
sampling and their power law decay
compared to the randomized algorithm
with the same level of error and it
depends on epsilon yeah so so my problem
that I'm interested in is Ridge
regression so it's used to solve
regularized oposed least squares
problems so in contrast to the other
talks I'm interested in choosing fewer
features not choosing heavy weight
samples so my my selection matrix goes
between a and X rather than on the left
and so this is the ridge regression
problem
I'm short on time so I won't talk about
it and super much detail but basically
you have your least squares problem and
you have this regularization term and
there are these exact solutions and so
if you have a model for data generation
where you don't actually observe Y which
is this which is this function of
coefficients x times your matrix a but
you observe a noisy version of it you
can calculate what the risk of the
estimator is for ridge regression and
this is my question was well what if I
use my sub matrix C to do Ridge
regression rather
my fault matrix a what sort of error do
I get and so other people have done a
really nice massage of this Ridge
regression risk and it goes as you might
expect into two terms a bias term and a
variance term and you can see that this
bias term has a very suggestive
subjective form you can see why these
bounds on a transport n't we can use our
bounds that we've we've derived for for
CC transpose in terms of a transpose to
bound the quantities of the bias and the
variance so we use the bounds which I've
only told you about but all the details
are in the paper to bound this risk so
the bound exists its multiplicative in
this form and there are constants you
can figure out what they are and you can
compare to the elastic net elastic net
risk so basically what you're doing by
doing column subset selection is you're
forcing 0 entries and your matrix these
are the areas that your matrix are not
sensitive to the coefficients so you're
setting them to 0 and then you also have
the shrinkage for Ridge regression so
it's a different way of getting sparsity
so experiments I have slides that are
essentially I think going to just tell
you you can choose very few features out
of 70 70 thousand you choose 1500 and
there are biological signatures and the
data which are meaningful your Ridge
regression does a good job whether you
see your a and predicting this
biological feature and I'm happy to tell
you more about these experiments offline
to not take too much time so I really
appreciate your listening
these were my postdoc advisers I'd also
like to thank Michael Mahoney and his
group for listening to me talk about
this work my ancestry.com for supporting
me and being here and you folks for
listening
the questions you can see quickly how
compares to oh I don't I can't say yeah
I'm not sure that wasn't a comparison
when we did those from snip day that
mystic future selection with respect to
leverage horses what we did for bio
journals you cannot do randomized
selection doesn't like to run the same
algorithm and get n different groups of
features that they cannot so you
mentioned in the spectral balance
discussion that when you randomize the
CC transport matrixes the columns are we
weighted the selected conservative
weighted case they're not they're not
related yeah in the application in a
regression see the dishes that the Bible
has selected in your method before
seeing the why yes it's hard to make a
comparison because the you know the last
party lasting had actually set some
marbles to zero right right so that so
there's two different ways you can set
the coefficients equal to zero
so unless the last su looks at why this
procedure doesn't look at why it looks
at the structure of a and says which
components of my regression regression
coefficients am I just not sensitive to
in my matrix essentially can I solve
them by changing the weights of my other
coefficients so you can do prediction
but the Bible selection with the green
of software before even see my yeah I
think that's interesting isn't that you
have to be really lucky no basis pursuit
that it takes into account the while
this is this yeah I'm just saying so
people have done that in the past where
they defied pca first to DX and then
typically terrible because we can you
have to guess assess your guess and what
both are important
short in fat so i'm saying which
features are essentially easy to write
as linear combinations of other features
so so like this is yes it's not looking
at y but it's looking at a and a matters
and the regression to because it's a dot
product so good
get people out for coffee thank you very
much thank you
[Applause]